yo do you weird guy huh yeah well you
know what I thought you were unique
Bobby was when you got when you have
that I know you told talk about on stage
when you said you got molested you know
yeah yeah yeah cuz I dealt with the
mentally handicapped we have a bunch a
mentally handicapped boss when I was
growing up and they were wild what do
you mean why lose they had this one man
was a farmer I guess mostly livestock so
yeah you know living crops yeah and he
he had a couple of mental sons and they
called him enols ort ism if somebody had
that ISM that's when they yeah had
autism but they didn't want to make it
fancy his autism so French really so you
just have that ISM yeah you know ISM and
he had a couple [ __ ] sons and I
don't mean to say if anybody is [ __ ]
I'm not talking about you I'm talking
about these other [ __ ] people that I
knew when I was going and he uh he had
two [ __ ] sons I would always be on
horseback and so they were yeah because
they were live soccer yeah yeah yeah and
they had all this yeah he's too busy
trying to so so what do they do to you
anybody anything no well they had one of
them eventually got injured I guess he
got injured somehow and then they got
him a bicycle that had a one of those
you know mothers used to have a bicycle
with that baby seat on the back yeah
yeah yeah
with that small baby seat like now they
put you in like this covered Conestoga
wagon and like you're like there's like
roll bars and stuff like I remember back
in the day you used to like the kid
would just be like a still like that
yeah yeah like not even in the mother
side side yeah
yeah good luck back to here dunno I was
in Thailand just real quick I saw a dude
on a moped right he was wearing this
[ __ ] motorcycle helmet oh he had a
baby on his shoulder baby had no helmet
you might as well just take the helmet
officer and just tie your baby to your
head use the baby as the helmet right I
mean yeah it does fate practice right
right we don't put a helmet on a baby
yeah
that's risky right one of these guys got
up was mentally challenging he got a
bicycle eventually and they gave him the
bike had a like a child mother's baby
seat on the back yeah and I had never
met anybody that was gay they didn't
have a lot of gay people in our area and
if they did we didn't know about until
we're older where did you grow up in
Louisiana and they didn't come by and
also you know when you grow up in like a
rural area like nobody really cares if
somebody's gay sound like they're
running around like they don't have a
gay pride parade you know because only
two gay dads if it meet up in the street
they're probably just gonna [ __ ] a
little you know they're not gonna put
together a whole parade for everybody so
but people said that this man was a
homosexual yeah and they didn't have and
everybody's like wow and they said that
they said he had a husband like a little
husband that left him that you just sit
in that back seat so there was always
like a ton of not remorse really I don't
know what the feeling is but when you
saw this man go by you were like oh
that's so sad
that his little husband that it's
remorse yeah and it was just sad you
know cuz you're like oh this guy had a
little husband that left him and so I
believe everything you're saying cuz we
watched a documentary called mommy dead
and dearest and everyone's from
Louisiana but like in the Bayou remember
how they talked yeah yeah
yeah III think that like it's just
simpler you just learn things like in a
different way you know also like I'm
sure like you're in a small town the two
gate is people know them right right so
there's not like it I think in the media
when you see like you know Republicans
talk right and they talk about you know
that they don't believe in you know gay
riots or whatever right that's just the
in the media but I think in small towns
they accept them right a hundred percent
like that's the crazy thing like the
only time anybody ever put anybody on
television from my area was when like
they needed somebody who'd seen an alien
or something yeah yeah otherwise these
people are mostly doing good stuff you
know yeah it's just like they always go
to like one or two spots and pick out
the worst yeah right and I think they'd
do it for almost everything you know but
um
never saw an alien growing up let me
thank you know one of my buddies died he
was on oxycottons and he choked to death
on a some type of a meat bone or
something but it was chicken fowl I
thought after he died that he came to
see me a couple times so not alien that
you're talking about go tell ghost and
you're talking about the paranormal
you're talking about not read the rest
real not extra traction yeah
so you he when he came back that he
looked like an alien did he look like it
was almost 40 was outside as himself I
felt like it was him but he seemed a
little bit more you know kind of Randi
than he used to be a little more active
yeah all right well cuz you get a little
bit I bet you once you're dead you're
like oh I'm free you know that's your
Amistad man you're out of your body you
know you're about do you believe in that
in afterlife I do because we came here
like people I was like you think you go
to like a magical place in the sky you
know and everybody's just sitting around
and [ __ ] drinking rocket sauce and
doing magic you know yeah and I'm like
look where I'm at now bro I'm in the
middle of [ __ ] about the [ __ ] dirt
yeah this happened yeah that's the only
proof I have so do I think it's
something like this could happen again
yeah I have to think that so when people
like you think you go to a crate a place
where there's a bunch of other people
that you don't know like if you're
talking about heaven you know and
everybody's doing good and I'm like yeah
we just like here but everybody would be
doing good you know yeah yeah yeah so I
base it on it's almost more like
reincarnation a little bit yeah I you
know I don't necessarily like geared
towards it's always believed like and
things that are factual but Wow but I do
believe in like sort of like the
paranormal stuff because when you live
in a big city like this you're so all
your senses are drowned out constantly
by the noise of traffic by people around
you there's always chaotic but when I go
back to the provincial areas and the
Philippines you do sense something
different there you
thinks more you feel things more yeah
and I always get sort of a sense of like
that paranormal stuff when I'm back
there but never here in LA it's called
boredom it's not boredom yeah you think
goes come here I wake up no this is what
happens la I wake up a [ __ ] I gotta go
here I gotta go to Starbucks I gotta get
the iPad store get my thing screen fixed
you me and I'm gonna go see uh Joe some
friend yeah I was in a [ __ ] vape
store yeah why and then you go to an a
meeting that I got two shows to do yeah
you got [ __ ] to do
over there you wake up there's nothing
to do oh I see a ghost yeah
I see it yeah it's like something like
Oh what are we gonna do today right Zach
there's nothing to do yes your mind and
right am I not right babe or no no okay
I just through it all you you kind of
reinforce what I was saying which is you
don't allow yourself to feel anything
because you pack your day with so much
and your feelings here it's hard to get
your feelings have no space here like I
can't even feel that much here you know
like I'm far more I noticed once soon as
I get outside of the city limits I'm far
more and you know I'm not trying to be
profane buddy erect dick has feeling
again yes
my life has feeling again like I don't
see how people have any feet there's no
room for your feelings here there's just
no you can't relax I can't anyway maybe
if you were brought up in this type of
environment yeah I'm like that in New
York really yeah if I'm wake when like
when I wake up in a hotel room in New
York with all the noise and all that
stuff I could probably sleep for four
hours I mean am I just walking around
right I just cannot sleep hmm it's just
if there's excitement in the air the
[ __ ] to do I don't know one time I was
in [ __ ] New York and I meet I don't
know how I ran into it I ran into Maz
Jobrani hmm he's like Indian or some
[ __ ] yeah what is this uh Pakistani or
whatever and he got a he goes hey dude
you want to go to a Moroccan like
nightclub but it's like an invite-only
and it's illegal I want to go I want to
go when they're those two things
Moroccan illegal I have to go to
elephant Valley I'm there okay
a time he steps through a red door we
walk in and then there's like a fire
right and there's people with bongo
drums the tribal smoking like see yes
smoking things and people are dancing
right and I just started I started
dancing too because I didn't know what
the [ __ ] to do I was scared yeah right
because mas started to I think I'm ed
was there too oh I miss and that's what
to me New York is you know so when I'm
in LA I feel relaxed mm-hmm right and if
I go to like wherever you're from I
probably go into coma
yeah yeah I probably go into coma and
never wake up again
[Music]